oh
[Music]
this is so good what is happening there
reject nation
greg and john we are going to watch
today superman and lois
episode 10 a show that really upsets me
that more people are not watching or
talking about it because it is so good
guys hit that like button if you have
enjoying our reaction subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up
full length watch alongs it's ready to
sync up with the time code
are over at our patreon page of the tone
there for a reason
and over there we cover many shows we're
at the same tier you get the option for
both
watch along and reaction highlights for
like some of these shows that i'm sure
i've flashed thumbnails for here
got to thank prithom jindal for being a
great dude and for editing these
highlights down for us
lastly um i've seen a bit out of it
i feel good right now shooting this uh
the day after loki
had a goal to get that up early i don't
think it's going to get up that early
ever again
because i only got an hour and a half of
sleep but i feel good right now
so let's swing into action for this
seriously incredible
what i consider underrated show
[Music]
brother martha can't slept with someone
else oh
no okay you are not my brother
i am kalel
i thought griptony just spoke english
[Music]
i'm the son of zetaro and lara lovan
okay my mother married jarrell your
father yes i know
years after she'd been matched to my
father it was when she first warned that
krypton was dying
very reason oh my father sent me here
i was the first son of krypton to leave
and i came here with one purpose to
further our kryptonian heritage
oh oh my god margaret hold on it's a boy
don't you move
i think don't move oh what'd you protect
deserves better than those who inhabit
oh
hey mom and park can't and we'll have
our mother
with us once again ooh that is tempting
help me do that brother not like this
fight
our people will awaken soon
i need you by my side or you will be
eradicated
oh owie i love that flashback of morgan
edge
it's like he could have probably ended
up like clark from
some way i believe he didn't try to
shoot it first
jonathan
i love that flashback two sides of the
same coin in a lot of ways
i really need you to tell me what
happened
she's still not answering i'll send
someone to her house
lois you're not gonna believe what i've
heard i've got a whole other family
lara's invention was a means of
preservation to save our people
by retaining and transferring their
minds just as my own mind has been
retained ears
i can't let this happen the eradicator
is well beyond my understanding
it's your mother's invention she
developed this technology
i cannot help you damn kryptonian women
that's what happens when you let women
work on projects
i just got sick and tired of messing up
with you
with our girls okay they got two
daughters i know it's just
she's got a sister we've seen like once
and what was this process
exactly we went into this this machine
and where was that to the limit
uh-oh did kryptonian boy take over yeah
he's got
spiders he's got these kryptonian eyes
hey lois everything okay
to stop by to check in on me
golly jesus christ
it's escalated quickly whoa
oh that's right mother damn not bad all
of a sudden now we're gonna love having
these krypton weapons on hand
kryptonite weapons
good job hmm you okay no
not really imagine what kyle's like at
the bedroom one
harder better faster stronger the theory
is powers only hold with smallville
natives people who have had prolonged
exposure
like kyle and emily and basically
everyone i recruited for the executive
program
you did such a good job lana oh except
i do see one thing odd him
dr dabney donovan he was the one who
conducted all the health exams for
everyone in the executive program
dual phds in genetics and molecular
neurochemistry
do you know where these health exams are
placed no that was top secret
kaiser permanente
[Laughter]
great group rates local state fbi i want
the cub scouts after this guy
i figure it can't hurt to ask at least
it can't hurt me
where is this man do you even realize
the threat you now face
all i wanted was some good conversation
the crispy kryptonian sir the truth
about your dad is that
he is really messed up yeah john i know
no
not from drinking morgan edge did
something damn
this is gonna sound nuts but he's
basically been body snatched
body snatched they're looking at your
dad right now trying to help him but i
honestly i don't even think that they're
totally clear on what's going on
it's not his fault it's definitely not
your mom's fault you're not supposed to
share the family secrets man maybe you
should go see for yourself
but i trust sarah yeah
uh jonathan is just the best human being
clark why would edge give superman time
to make a decision
edge is a ruthless corporate shark he
never gives anyone anything
maybe the subjects aren't finished
resurrecting or transforming or whatever
the process is because they're not
done
[Music]
they found donovan guess i'll uh go out
the back
out the back yeah
you can just stay low flat and then
to the cornfield yeah just hover a foot
off the ground
we need to reverse what this machine's
been doing to people i barely understand
how this technology even works
if you want to reverse this process
you're gonna have to find whoever it is
that invented this thing who the hell is
that oh no
oh no oh
clark my mother
oh man bring her back to life in that
scientist's body put her in lowest spot
that'll get confused oh no
so the only way this works is to place
the consciousness of lara lorvan into
someone from smallville
that's my understanding get this machine
ready i have the perfect subject
yeah i got someone we could sacrifice
we need to find a volunteer fast no i'll
do it no jesus
god no this isn't your responsibility
i'm the one who stood by while kyle
rallied the town to edge's side
but you have a family yeah and my
husband is one of them
if there's a chance that he's still
alive i have to do it
there's no guarantee this will even work
this is alien science
well it's a good thing i'm just a local
loan officer who doesn't know any better
you got this lana
i don't get it you said that there'd be
some kind of you think your little toys
could stop us
dad dad oh daddy doesn't exist anymore
sarah let's just let's just get out of
here kryptonian's so evil yeah i know
can there be one transplant of like a
nice guy
but it's lana she's one of my closest
friends which is why you should say
something
even if it says you wouldn't mean a lot
hello citizen my
superman nice to meet you for the first
time i want to thank you
it's very brave you know you don't have
to do this there's always another way
did superman just lie to me it's not
lying i'm just uh i'm just an optimist
guess that's what makes you a hero
you're the hero right now
lana it's time
we'll be right here oh
boy oh boy
[Music]
what if what if the mom's evil too in
this show i
i i'm quite curious
seems like only joral and kalel turned
out cool
did it work is he okay
[Music]
brother we're destroying this planet
come with me it was never meant to be
used as a way to supplant another race
kryptonians are peaceful people your
father and i
when we decided to send you to earth we
hoped you would live that vision you
think i have
this world it welcomed you it has
and you found someone i can tell by how
you look at her
mm-hmm yeah
she's hot she's pretty badass too all i
ever wanted for you
to find a new home someone to love
create a family of your own
hmm we have two sons tell me all about
them
twitter's not gonna get any work done
[Laughter]
ever and i wish i wish things weren't
the way that they are
what's up with that soda
i'll take this one to go something
seemed pretty off from
just a featured background extra what's
going on here
really too much into it okay you spike
that water with ex kryptonite
calling my dad drunk gonna be the last
thing i ever said once oh
i need him back
i'll find them there's no need leave and
prepare for our arrival
carl made his decision there's no saving
my brother now
oh damn get
get gerard
yeah light the hammer signal
and then the new consciousness fully
takes over how long does that take
days weeks and how do we stop this
prevent the transfer from completing so
only the old consciousness remains
oh [ __ ] we just need to get the people
who were affected to go through the
eradication process again
but we don't know how many people have
gone through this there has to be
another way to do it all at once
that would require too much energy we
would need something that rivals this
planet's son
[Music]
figure out a way to do everyone at once
i'll hold him off as long as i can hmm
be the hero i knew you would be
[Music]
that's good music this is a freaking
movie i don't care what anyone says
look at this how cinematic
superman hope guy
i love how kryptonians don't want to
wear black that's bad
when you first arrived did they treat
you like you were one of them because
they did no such thing for me
you kept hidden from the world for years
a piece of alien
meat an experiment brother i am sorry
that happened to you
and not everyone here is like that only
when they're afraid
i made them afraid
[Music]
dude i'm gonna do it again
without you i love this character love
him
you're the new kyle he's a good
character man
absolutely absolutely they pay off so
far
tell me do you plead
[Laughter]
most of the time it's easy and sometimes
it's very difficult i meant to radically
yes is he pleasing your needs there's
always love
and respect he's woke it's called
superman and lois
here you go oh
no oh i knew there was something up with
that guy
[Music]
is so good
you're so better this is the only planet
you've ever known
so you don't know the pain of losing one
but i do and i am not going to let that
happen again
and neither are they oh
wow no what a shot in the light why are
more people not watching
holy [ __ ] look at this
[Music]
the use of the sun in this episode too
like oh
there is no us or them
oh god
sam we're out of time is it ready it is
except for that energy source part yes
we do me
what i'll release all my energy at once
create a solar flare
it'll be enough get everyone out i'm
coming in and so are they
everyone out just gonna jam them all in
there isn't it
oh
oh appeal to him come on appeal to him
he can resist the kryptonian the one
person you love more than morgan edge
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a shot what a
shot
did did it work
just it's going to be raining bodies in
a minute
sarah dad oh
not penny's boat
[Music]
tom sagura
my head hurts from falling several
thousand feet
lana lois
hell yeah
no sign of morgan edge search the globe
until you find him
oh say he's definitely earned a little
solitude
ugh
just us but now but all is not lost
what what's there god
damn it what's there what what what
what
overrated this is a pile of rocks what
are you gonna do with that
look you know i know everyone's worry is
that
eventually this amazing ass cw
show is gonna go down the toilet
but hell that is a this is a freaking
fantastic first season how many episodes
are we in
this is ten wow it almost felt like some
kind of mid-season finale
god that's so good yeah right that's so
good like the wasting no time with the
drama
and the steaks like seriously naked
sophisticated
story choices keeping the thrills high
pisses me off that more people are
watching this dude
let's uh let's take it to the streets
then
anyway let's talk about all right guys
here's the reality of the situation we
have landed ourselves in
we shot this and then um i had to go to
therapy
and um had to stand outside because
there's no privacy here in the car i
have right now currently doesn't have a
working ac
so just out on the balcony sweating
balls and before
um i went to therapy i put out a little
tweet
uh a very honest tweet so honest i'm
gonna share with you all right now
hot off the press sweet is i'm just
stalling
i said guys listen a lot of people are
turned off by the dc
cw shows now i'm telling you give
superman and lois a chance
it starts off strong and just keeps
getting better
it feels more and more like a movie as
it progresses
and then a lot of comments came in that
echo the same kind of thing that i was
that talked about while right after it
ended with um
you know uh i hope the cw show doesn't
really change
like i hope it doesn't fall off and
become like the other ones blah
blah blah i saw this one comment that
really pissed me off
here let me read it
[Laughter]
i'm excited this is good drum roll john
5 6 8 1 0 4 nine eight
not gonna lie it's kind of hard to leave
you because you clap for pretty much all
of them but i will give it a try
okay wow and i get it i do i think i had
to take a second to think about that
shots fired um this guy is a miserable
lonely [ __ ]
that's the reason i hate him everybody's
dive bomb his twitter again no i get it
i do um
it's because when we cover trailers
this is a little bit of a side tangent
you recover trailers
what what i think we the approach we
take is
it's a freaking trailer so we're gonna
give it the benefit of the doubt we'll
say what looks stupid what might be
bad but we always go off maybes you know
like uh
especially when it comes to the bad
stuff like this might not be good this
this is where it might falter
la la la we usually enjoy the trailer
but we'll be honest about some
things but we tend to lean more toward
the optimistic
hopeful side because it's a trailer when
it comes time to reviewing things though
i think we're very honest typically yeah
jordan for example jordan haven't had
the best relationship with some superman
and lois fans
from me to you guys yeah those early
episodes it was rough going with some of
those jordan criticisms
yes it was very honest about those
criticisms and even then i would try to
be like well maybe this maybe that
why they're doing this or my work but i
was also still
honest about i wasn't liking him and i
wasn't liking it
so screw that guy
i mean like you might watch our
conjuring reaction see the thumbnail and
be like
wow they look terrified but then you've
listened to review i clearly didn't like
the movie
yeah yeah and i mean you know this is a
little different
all these formats bring something a
little bit different and in this format
here's the evidence we're actually
watching the show
yes and then you know you can watch as
the reviews and the responses grow over
the course of it
so let me segue uh by transit
tying it back into this looping it back
into here this to me is an example of
damn good television because
that comment made me i think like what i
told the guy basically was i
completely fell off flash dc's legends
of tomorrow for a reason and i
couldn't get into batwoman or uh super
girl but i love this so there's an
example of
how i didn't like some shows all right
but
with this one it does it i mean that
what i tweeted out i really mean
because while i thought it had a really
strong opening there are things that i
that do that i wasn't too keen on even
last week we were kind of talking about
sarah
and saying how some of the dramatic
stuff with her seems to be
rather tropey and it doesn't look like
they really know what to do with it
sometimes so they just kind of
chuck her up to angsty teen daughter and
don't really flesh her out too much
that's how we were honestly feeling and
then in here she moved
me so much i thought she was excellent
her performance was brilliant
and the the relationship dynamics that
she has formed with
jordan and jonathan are so good and the
way how
the way how this is just such good
serial storytelling to the point where
it feels progressively more cinematic
is excellent like how they have gone
from this
this episode which is pretty low key you
think you're probably gonna get into
this like
extreme [ __ ] from the last episode you
know
but it's pretty it's pretty tamed yeah
you get some morgan edge backstory
and then there's a lot of just this one
containment camp with the doa
and everyone's just huddling around
there and then even
superman's mom gets brought back and she
just stays
there you know they're not really moving
around a lot
yeah and there's not a bunch of action
but it's building
it's building so when they all start
launching when all the kryptonians just
thought
it is scary it is intense it is
gripping that
that this show has earned that you know
and it keeps
earning that and it just keeps getting
better like you can earn these episodes
that are just
scene driven yeah you think you're gonna
get into
oh we're about to get into crazy morgan
edge versus clark [ __ ]
but no it's still very very
character driven and i love that about
this show
i think this show is extremely
underrated and it's too bad all these cw
shows have kind of put a bad taste in
people's mouths that they're not
not as many people are giving the show a
chance yeah i mean
it really it does i don't know i mean
with the other cw shows i don't have
anywhere near the experience you do but
it feels like another caliber even just
compared to the other cw
shows i have seen and yeah i mean the
storytelling
feels akin to something different than
what you usually associate with network
tv and yeah when you are dealing with
these incredibly high
stakes and huge power arrays like i i
was
impressed at how you know much of a
moment they make out of that because
you're like okay well maybe he's buying
time because you know not everyone's
uh you know kryptonian uh spirit
transplant has taken hold and when he
finally like throws the switch and
everyone
starts shooting up into the air you
realize like oh wow this is
way further along than i thought you
know this is a dire
situation and uh you know even the way
it resolves like it is a really big
event to have happen
uh you know on episode 10 but at the
same time it feels
plausibly within the realm of the scope
that they have established
and you when you've got all the
kryptonians firing their their you know
ocular beams at
the um uh what's it called again
the obliterator the annihilator the
eradicator the eradicator which is such
a foreboding
that was the only that was the only
detail that semi pulled me out i was
like if this thing is meant to like
keep the longevity of your people going
and to you know transfer their
consciousness
i would call it something a little less
evil sounding
um but yeah like they they really
managed to make this this sci-fi
story and and come up with this
emotional
uh uh flavor in transplanting
you know carl's mom's consciousness into
lana that i wasn't expecting
at all and that i thought at the outset
could maybe feel
a bit too much or a bit cheesy or
something but within the rules they
established and everything
i thought it really worked oh yeah i
mean i think with superman he
he can if anyone could look past
the the physical being of lana lange and
actually see his mother
it'd be superman a guy who deals with
x-ray vision and being able to hear
people's heartbeats and all these things
you know you can see who the real the
entity the who the spirit is underneath
it all and communicate with that
and not be distracted by the uh body
it's inhabiting
you know so yeah that was that was all
great great scenes like he got to have
his resolve with his mom
technically you know in that scene i get
like i'm waiting to see what amps up if
i if i did have a criticism i i do think
that uh it seemed a little convenient
uh how they
wha whatever that device this is the
eradicator that they had to
blow up right the laser them all into
they spent all this time building up
these kryptonians and
yadda yadda build up all these people
and then we need something to eliminate
all them right away
yeah and then they figure it out in like
it's not 10 minutes in the show's time
but from the run time
it's like 10 minutes you know and so
they
they solved it it seemed like they
solved it pretty quick and then oh all
those crypto
you seem like you're gonna get some like
epic ass battle or something like that
you're like you're gonna end this with a
cliffhanger there's just a bunch of
crazy kryptonians there you know
just the world yeah smallville at least
is infested with them
yeah and then kyle we gotta deal with
him too like it's it really felt like
they were built into that and it they
had a solution of
like it's clever to bring back you know
uh mommy carl whose name i know
i it's bothering me so much as i know
the mom's name and it's
really picking at my skull right now how
i
cannot recall it in this time
karen it's i'm so annoyed it's like
i can remember freya ooh but i can't
freaking remember carl's mom's name
right now
what the hell is wrong with me some
iteration she's just called laura
that's not her name la uh
okay lar something around whatever
carl's mom
all right i'm just going to admit defeat
here mommel
mom elm but uh yeah like having her come
back was it was
was used wonderfully and then having
lana feel like she has to
this is her way of earning her way by by
uh being the volunteer
uh for this situation and it was an
appropriate fit you know like it's her
hubby who's
in the kryptonite jail and
and uh a lot of what she was doing was a
contributing factor to this development
that she had no
she wasn't aware she didn't do it
intentionally but she wasn't aware
but she was a contributing factor to it
all even though it wasn't her fault i
got to make that clear i don't think
it's her fault
no i could see how she felt there was a
responsibility on her
like it may not have been her fault but
now it's her responsibility to do
something about it yeah
and uh i admire that they really made
what they've done with lana with
like making her she's such a great
character like she's so nuanced
and uh kyle's never been more
interesting as not being kyle
i know i know but i thought
but i thought that did a really nice uh
it was a nice icebreaker because too
they've had all this stuff about like oh
jordan thing's going down with him and
he wants to talk to sarah and
how is he gonna tell her and i thought
they kind of side doored that in a
really
in a way that felt very practical but
also felt very sort of emotionally true
which is like look her
her dad's been pulled into this like we
just have to tell her what's going on
and we don't have to tell her
necessarily that hugh jordan are
becoming a super boy but we can tell her
you know basically
the extent of what's going on and i like
that they don't
you know spin their wheels with stuff
like that and it made
room for even like there i feel like
there are a lot of scenes in this
episode that if it wasn't handled so
well they could have played as silly or
cheesy but it even gives jonathan
another moment to step up to his
grandfather who
jonathan is just becoming like uh sam's
conscience
at this point um but yeah like and
leading to that scene between her and
kyle like
all of those moments i thought played
really nicely and it enhances you know
like there's such a physical
foreboding you know stakes that comes
with all these kryptonians you know
being
transplanted into people but that with
him contained makes it this really
emotionally messed up thing
too you know that's you know it's like
we get the emotional side kind of
through clark because of
obviously it's his family it's his
people but uh yeah
in a more down to earth kind of way too
through that you know
yeah i i what were you just talking
about
hour and a half asleep people okay uh
you know just just revealing to sarah
like the circumstances i remember i
don't remember what i was gonna say
the like sam the moment i really liked
here with uh
sam was the moment with jonathan because
what hit me of a big part that separates
this sometimes they have it where
they're setting up with a lesson that
this character has to learn in this
episode
but what i've really noticed from the cw
shows
is it's a very apparent lesson they're
gonna have to learn
and then by the end of this episode
they're gonna learn this lesson
okay it's such a like for as much as
those
shows are still serial they felt
episodic in that sense
and then here with someone like sam
while he learned a lesson in the last
episode
that arc of him learning is not his
learning has only begun
yeah and that carried through in that
scene here with jonathan
and i think that's cool because i feel
like in other cw shows he might have
just learned his lesson in the last
episode a different character
yeah totally totally but he still has to
learn it makes them more
human in that way and that's and makes
the uh
significance of watching all the
episodes that much more
felt you know it's good and morgan edge
uh like another character was very
caricature and then suddenly you're like
damn i get this guy now that's awesome
like he's i'm not rooting for this guy
but
i get the guy and he's i love the
parallel of draws of like freaking clark
king grows up in
sunny sunny small grows up in a levi's
commercial while you're being hunted
like a fox and he's got like occasional
bullying to deal with
but you know and it's just a test of
like just don't murder them
you know like self-control yeah instead
of self-preservation
and and more importantly he's gifted
with amazing parents
uh to look after him whereas this kid's
first arrival is
shoot that kid and then everyone just
starts
hunting him down he's thrown in jail
you're like
oh and and like this the the final
speech he's giving
to clark about like basically their
differences in
their perspectives on humanity is
such a great monologue he's giving like
he that's
like oh he feels he feels human you know
there was a caricature thing going on
about him and then
that even got better that's what i mean
like i respect the show
where i i love when there's things that
i'm like i don't like this
or there's a flaw here that is really
not jiving with me
or that i perceive to be a flaw maybe
you don't
i do and then to go oh
crap i'm on board now yeah let's see
what that developed into
i love when a show can do that i love i
love when a show can do that where
you're like
ah so i got to give a show a chance yeah
i got to see where the riders were going
you know because they had that up their
sleeve
you know yeah especially one that plays
with appearances and alter egos as much
as these stories do
and it's just shot so good yeah like
they have
maintained that it is just so like
there's occasional vfx that are off
like when the first time they're uh
zipping around the
grand canyon or wherever they are red
desert places
yeah there's times they look very
computer agent smith and eui yeah
yeah and it's hard because it's harder
especially because they're in the
daylight so they're trying to mask it
with the shadows of that landscape
i could it was like i could see what
they're trying to do now to
hide their uh limited ability to
make this look incredible yeah but
whenever you're in daytime
it's always going to be more challenging
uh that's why
zack snyder just really you know darkens
the [ __ ] out of his lenses
yeah that's right man get those
monochrome
times and those lush blue night times
but
for the most part the effects are still
really damn good and the cinematography
even some of like the most simple shots
maybe it's on the highlights because
maybe you had to cut it out due to time
but
when uh clark approaches lois
before he's like maybe i should go out
the back there's this like
master shot where they're framed to the
right
and it's just their picket white house
to the left
and he's just approaching her they'd
like miniature and scale and then the
background is just completely out of
focus
and like this shot doesn't need to be
this beautiful it doesn't need to be
and it's not one of their action shots
or their awe-inspiring super heroic
shots
but damn that's a good-looking shot you
know yeah
yeah yeah it's one of those shows where
seldom are shots wasted
and and i thought this one also did a
very interesting job of really
emphasizing the sun
in several instances most probably most
notably obviously in the jail sequence
with young
teenager morgan edge or whatever but
they you know for
for a power set that is driven by the
sun's
radiation i i thought that was a nice
subtle thing that
they've probably done throughout the
previous episodes too but i noticed it
especially here
uh and yeah it just it goes to show how
much
character and you know it it's true to a
comic book too i mean as
as cinematic as this feels you know
every panel of a comic book
you're taking that opportunity to go
well i can make this anything i might as
well try and make every panel
as great as possible and you you get
that sense behind the camera absolutely
and it seems like as much care is put
into yeah
all of these character-driven dialogue
scenes as much as it is you know the
cool action and and
the plot driven stakes
yeah this is great that's just great
what do i know i clap for everything
it's all good everything is everything
is good
every movie and show every movie is a
full price
uh is worth every every buy it on
blu-ray no alcohol required
you love something or like something the
haters come at you
because you love everything when you
love something and you dislike something
or hate
something that everything the defenders
come at you yeah
that's what happens can't we just get a
little bit of both each time
just even it out so many channels i
watch
all the time who i like i disagree with
on so much
but i'm constantly like i'm never like
hell with you nah you gotta get in the
comments and you gotta let them know
you gotta give them a piece of your mind
you guys hate everything all right guys
well
thank you so much for being here what do
you think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button thank you so much
for joining us last but not least let's
do up
maria hammond maria my dear
listen i'm looking at my twitter
messages right now
and apparently you forwarded john is
what happens when people can't get a
hold of john
dude i'm following you now marie's only
messaging me
maria like trying to get in touch with
john
greg that's right man that's that's what
that's
my personal assistant how do you like
that all right maria i'll just get you
over here
i'm not bothered by it maria uh i know i
know sometimes i make jokes you get a
little bit sensitive bye but i just mean
that in
all kidding so uh
i wanted to say that i hope that you did
not just skip to your
shout out so this shout out makes sense
and maybe you watch the show
but listen if there was
to be a mother in this world who
we would need to bring back to to
instill a consciousness into
a different person's body in order to
solve
a heart-wrenching problem you're that
mother maria again if you just skip to
your shout out this makes
no sense but if you watch the episode
you'll get it and it's endearing so yeah
you're very important
the the fate of the world rests in your
hands maria you're an incredible human
being
and i appreciate the hell out of you and
uh
you know i worked out in that nelson and
murdoch shirt uh
the other day and someone said daredevil
so that's always feels nice when you got
street cred
yeah they said where'd you get that and
i said
maria maria hammond and he said you know
maria
oh god i gotta shout her out and then
pull down the mask
it was john at the gym dude
and then i proceeded to unfollow you on
twitter immediately after that
but don't worry i'm following you again
now so this shouldn't happen anymore
no you're the best you're a sweetheart
and uh i really adore you and i
i sincerely appreciate everything you've
uh
not what you've given i appreciate the
i don't want to just say emotional
support the feelings you bestow upon us
that are incredibly flattering
and uh empowering i would say so
thank you you rock see here's the thing
it's like
calm greg is good with his words
excited greg claps for everything
excited
high energy greg is slow to find
the good vocabulary but calm greg can uh
formulate an appropriate sentence from
time to time it's good that's good it's
good to know about yourself
all right thank you maria